a small picturesque town on the Rhine
Mon Homme was founded over a thousand
years ago and has an old town that looks
like the set of a fairy tale today it
boasts some 40,000 inhabitants among
them one of the youngest mayor's in
Germany his stories sound like fairy
tales - when I became mayor in 2009 the
town was 120 million euros in debts now
were almost that much in the black this
is largely due to tax cuts in the past
five years together the town has had an
accumulated budget surplus of around 300
million euros hold on a minute the town
introduces tax cuts and ends up with a
huge surplus there are no traffic jams
every morning coming into Mon home
everyone seems to be coming to work here
at ecolab for instance the us producer
of cleaning supplies set up its German
headquarters in Mon home in 2012 and
it's only one of almost 300 companies
that have come in recent years the city
has acquired a reputation among foreign
companies as a kind of German tax haven
some of the city's industrial zones even
look like they could be in the Caribbean
estelle dagger rat is responsible for
business development at City Hall she
says interest continues to grow in five
years we've created 2,300 new jobs
that's incredible yes it's quite a few
can anywhere else in North
rhine-westphalia compared not that I
know of not that surprising Mon I'm has
lower business taxes than any other town
in the whole state such as Oberhausen
just 60 kilometers away chemicals firm
oxy Estill has its head office here but
next year the company wants to move it
to moon Heim
nataly's bar and insurance of course one
of the decisive factors apart from the
concrete object that we have our eye on
was the taxes and especially the
commercial taxes he wouldn't say how
much exactly the company will be saving
the production works will remain an
Oberhausen but headquarters and some 120
employees will move Oberhausen which is
already deeply in debt will lose
millions in revenue at City Hall people
are angry that mon home has introduced
such low tax rates I think it's really
sad Oxana has a long tradition here in
Oberhausen we're not losing it
completely because the industrial unit
will be staying here so the products
will still be made here this doesn't
mean that we'll be keeping a large part
of the taxes in the future there's a
danger that most of the taxes do will be
paid in Mon Hina if the company's head
office moves there the mayor of mon hime
is already looking forward to that is it
his fault that companies in Oberhausen
have to pay around ten percent more in
taxes than they do in Mon hime there are
other places outside of north
rhine-westphalia with tax loads that are
similar to those in more time that's why
I don't lose sleep over mr. Celeste res
complaints about Lorne hime because I
know these companies will go elsewhere
if there wasn't anything for them here
and it's totally aboveboard German
lawmakers want stands to compete over
companies at the moment Mon Homme is
leading the pack in its region and there
are still plenty of lots left in the
business park with a view over the Rhine
you